los científicos de todo el mundo están
en una carrera por poner fin a la
pandemia mediante el desarrollo de una
vacuna y américa latina es el terreno
para las pruebas desde que rusia anunció
en agosto la primera inyección contra el
coronavirus varios países
latinoamericanos se mostraron
interesados en recibir las dosis el
presidente vladimir putin acordó el
envío de 32 millones de ellas a mexico y
se establecieron pactos para enviar
hasta 100 millones a varios países de la
región entre ellos venezuela y el estado
de paraná en brasil
una vez terminado el periodo
investigación
hasta el final del año podremos ofrecer
la vacuna rusa a todo españa pero brasil
tiene además otro acuerdo para producir
la vacuna desarrollada por la
universidad de oxford y astrazéneca en
sao paulo al igual que méxico y
argentina en donde se producirá esa
inyección para toda la región a precios
asequibles de entre 3 y 4 dólares por
dosis en cuanto a la vacuna que
desarrolla la estadounidense johnson y
johnson son 6 los países con voluntarios
en las fases de prueba brass
colombia méxico chile argentina y perú
en este último esta semana 20 personas
comenzaron a recibir las primeras dosis
de una vacuna desarrollada por el
laboratorio chino sinovac participar en
nuestros estudios para el perú va a
permitir que perú pueda negociar con los
actores principales en el mundo de esta
de este esfuerzo que ha hecho todas las
instituciones en laboratorios para de
obtener un plazo relativamente corto una
vacuna cuba por su parte ya inició la
primera fase de su propia vacuna
soberana mientras que la organización
mundial de la salud junto con el
gobierno de costa rica lanzó en mayo un
grupo de trabajo para desarrollar una
eventual inyección